un profundo cráter edificios destruidos
y los bomberos tratando de apagar el
fuego
es el resultado del bombardeo ruso
contra la ciudad occidental de libia
ubicada a 70 km de la frontera con
polonia el ataque dirigido contra
instalaciones militares y un punto de
servicio de neumáticos dejó varios
muertos y heridos y es que en la
madrugada del lunes se vivieron
bombardeos masivos en todo el territorio
de ucrania así informó de la operación
el ministerio de defensa rusa las
unidades rusas atacaron durante la noche
315 objetivos de las tropas ucranianas
la aviación de las fuerzas
aeroespaciales rusas llevó a cabo
ataques en 108 áreas de concentración de
personal y equipo ucraniano los
esfuerzos militares rusos se están
concentrando en mariupol su conquista
permitiría conectar el donbass con la
anexión a la península de crimea así
estaba la fábrica de acero azul de este
domingo así se atrinchera el regimiento
ultranacionalista ucraniano conocido
como batallón azoz el presidente de
volodymyr selenski habló de las
intenciones rusas este lunes
las tropas rusas se están preparando
pero me ofensiva en el este de nuestro
país esto comenzará en un futuro cercano
literalmente quieren completar su
operación y destruir el donbass son vas
desde el kremlin aseguran que ucrania
incumple los acuerdos de las
conversaciones de paz y aprovecharon
para lanzar un mensaje a los que
considera países hostiles sobre el pago
de gas en rublos
estamos esperando los pagos por los
suministros que comenzaron después de
que se emitió el decreto presidencial a
fines de mayo entonces todavía hay
tiempo
desde europa a estos países han
rechazado la medida e incluso alemania
consideró que se trataba de un chantaje